il a traversé le temps et les frontières
le jello ce populaire dessert en
gélatine est toujours servi dans les
hôpitaux mais se déguste aussi avec les
yeux
depuis plus d'un siècle le jello fait le
plaisir des petits et aussi des grands
c'est très drôle parce qu'on associe le
jello à un produit familial peu cher
mais quand on y pense les aspects et les
gelés de la fin du Moyen-Âge c'était la
royauté qui mangeait ça la gélatine est
obtenue par l'ébullition prolongée du
collagène une protéine présente dans les
tissus et les eaux d'animaux bien que
cette gelée ait été brevetée en 1845
c'est une trentaine d'années plus tard
que le dessert le plus célèbre
d'Amérique sera créé par Pro et Medavie
et donc ce couple là va ajouter des
arômes artificiels à saveur de fruits
ils vont inventer ce dessert-là
[Musique]
savoureuse au départ c'était les fameux
saveurs le CF framboises fraises orange
citron à partir des années 30 on sort le
dilo à la lime et là on dit ben
attention c'est un produit santé et puis
il y a pas beaucoup de calories là
dedans
sans sucre ou aux légumes le jello a
tenté de séduire les personnes à la
recherche d'aliments faibles en calories
on sort des saveurs jello céleri djello
à la tomate assaisonnée et là vraiment
c'est à partir de là qu'on commence à le
server partout sur les tables il faudra
attendre 1914 pour que la marque gelo
apparaisse dans les foyers canadiens à
l'époque il était vendu 25 sous pour
trois paquets depuis il est resté un
produit très abordable
quand on va faire les premières
campagnes au début du 20e siècle la
saveur artificielle c'était
extraordinairement moderne c'était
révolutionnaire on se dit en plus pas
besoin de fabriquer de la gélatine à
partir des produits animaux nous-mêmes
pour la gélatine animale font avec
l'augmentation du végétalisme des
formules végétales comme la pectine de
fruits l'amidon ou la fécule de maïs
trouve maintenant leur place dans nos
recettes
la caraganine est également que la gare
à gaz on extrait des roues
a testé des gélatines végétaliennes avec
un résultat concluant
si on veut une couleur plus transparente
qui attire un petit peu plus je vous
suggère
des lots et l'agar-agar ça hygiène de la
Garaga on peut modifier moduler les
pouvoirs gélifiants en ajoutant ou en
allant mais je trouve que ça donne un
résultat pareil vraiment des commerces
et ici on a purée de fruits et
canagineux exactement
c'est plus une purée qu'une gélatine
mais la texture est intéressante et on
sent très bien le fruit gelo présente
une toute nouvelle saveur d'électeurs
[Musique]
quelques décennies plus tard les
desserts à la gélatine ont fait une
apparition en force sur les réseaux
sociaux
on remarque quand même sur Instagram
TikTok etc toutes ces belles
présentations de jello mais en même
temps depuis toujours on se servait de
cette gelée pour en faire des plats
magnifiques et il fallait être très
créatif inventifs
justement un dessert créatif qui a
marqué son enfance au Mexique
ça s'appelle chez latina de mosaïco la
cuisine s'allait toujours été très
important dans notre famille et ce
dessert c'était une classique dans les
feuilles d'enfant on veut des quand même
gros que ces bouquins dans notre
gélatine on voit des gros morceaux quand
on veut faire la vraie mosaïque on va
mettre la couleur on va mettre la vie
pour faire cette recette je vous
recommande fortement des enlever la
moitié de l'eau qui est dans la recette
parce que même texture très ferme qui
est un couple un morceau ça se tient
surtout quand on va ajouter le lait dans
ma famille c'est comme ça avec du lait
du lait condensé et la bonne vanille
mexicaine au Mexique et c'est un dessert
vraiment très commun mais c'est un
dessert qui est mangé dans plusieurs
pays en Amérique latine non exactement
je pense que toute la mairie de latine
on partage cette recette
[Musique]
les desserts à la gélatine sont aussi
populaires ailleurs dans le monde en
Asie c'est l'art floral qui a la cote
au Vietnam et depuis qu'elle s'est
installée au Québec en 2021 elle sculpte
des gâteaux en trois dimensions fait à
partir d'une gelée d'algues et de
colorants naturels
[Musique]
donc après une nuit au frigo on a notre
résultat final
[Musique]
dans le temps je retourne en enfance
chez moi
[Musique]